c'est depuis ses escaliers étroits du
13e purement militaire que les
mercenaires descendait dos au mur se
mettant alors en danger de mort lors des
assauts en face dans la cour centrale
ce puits avec sa gargouilles en pierre
calcaire armé d'une gouttière
ostentatoire purement décorative
faisaient à l'origine 80 mètres de
profondeur ils n'accusent plus que 30
aujourd'hui
l'effondrement a fait son oeuvre
désormais ces abîmes recueil sur tous
les portables des visiteurs distrait à
l'intérieur un escalier 14e irrégulier à
souhait mais nos caves indispensable au
moyen-âge
car la population consomme alors entre 1
et 3 litres de vin par jour pour soigner
la dysenterie mots particulièrement
courant à l'époque faute d'hygiène le
château de la madeleine regorge
d'anecdotes et autres récits
passionnants
situé sur les hauteurs de chevreuse
cette forteresse est intimement liée à
l'histoire de france en 13 106 philippe
lebel et l'impératrice de constantinople
il séjourne en 14 115 jean-sans-peur
alliés du roi d'angleterre livrent
bataille et laisse la ville en ruine au
xvième siècle les guerres de religion
font rage et le château déclaré félon
est finalement épargné par henri iv lui
même ici c'était ocm sexe était le
bastion catholique de l'île de france
c'était le pouvoir central de lentilles
pouvoir protestants il fallait vraiment
en découdre et symboliquement oreca
pouvait très bien le raser ce château
aujourd'hui visiter le château de la
madeleine c'est s'immerger dans dix
siècles d'histoire le donjon la tour des
gardes soeur jumelle de la tour de la
bastille et une croisée d'ogives
purement décorative le bourgeois
sin-le-noble première période bling
bling de l'histoire sans oublier une vue
imprenable du haut des remparts depuis
lesquels les visiteurs peuvent
contempler le bourg de l'an mil